every Economist expects inflation to
fall this year but the dissent is
proving stubbornly slow last month the
Consumer Price Index measure of
inflation did come down but it's still
in double digits at 10.1 driven largely
by food prices in food inflation running
at record
19.1 in March remember this is just the
average some Staples have gone up much
much more now these figures are bad news
at home but they're poor by
International standards too average
inflation the euro is only 6.9 in the US
five percent in Japan
3.3 we've already said food is a major
driver of this and this chart shows our
Reliance on Imports compared to the EU
in the middle column here and the US in
the dark blue here they're from before
the pandemic but you can see the UK is
way more dependent on Imports of oil
sugar and dairy products transport and
shipping costs go up as a result and
there's a brexit impact here too it's
added friction and cost to supply chains
then we have energy this chart shows the
domestic energy price Gap over the last
few years you can see the really big
leap in prices was between April 2021
and a year later after the start of the
Ukraine war that's an increase of almost
50 percent there now with government
support the rise in the year since then
has been much smaller around 25 because
inflation is an annual measure that
should drive the official figure down
but not till next month finally we have
the labor market wage inflation was
running at 5.9 percent in the three
months to February it's less than the
overall inflation figure the blue line
here and that means real wages are
actually falling but it also shows
employers are paying more to retain and
recruit staff because the workforce is
smaller than pre-pandemic there are more
than a million unfilled vacancies as
employers struggle to find workers not
helped Again by brexit now energy and
food prices will always fluctuate but
this is the sort of persistent domestic
inflation that will worry the chancellor
and the bank of England inflation should
still fall in the coming months but
there'll be cold comfort for consumers
prices won't be coming down they just
won't be going up quite as fast